now that we have covered arrangement of
digits
let's try arranging people say we have
five people and we have just three
chairs the chairs are placed in a row or
in a straight line five people and three
chairs with this situation in how many
ways do you think can these chairs be
occupied now if you've gone through our
previous sessions on forming numbers you
should quickly realize that this problem
is not too different
five people is analogous to five
different digits and three chairs are
analogous to the three slots for the
three-digit number we had to form
correct if you remember we were given
five digits and asked for the number of
three-digit numbers we can form here we
have been given five people and have
been asked for the number of ways in
which we can arrange any three of them
on these three chairs it's exactly the
same just that they have used chairs and
people instead of numbers and digits so
assume that these three chairs are like
three slots in how many ways can we fill
the first slot understand the question
well if we have five people and all
three chairs are empty in how many ways
can the first chair be occupied it's
logic any one of the five people can be
seated on this chair it's obvious the
chair can be occupied in five ways so
out of the five people one person is
seated on the first chair now now one
person having taken the seat in how many
ways can the second chair be occupied
one person is seated here it means one
of the five people is seated on the
first chair and any one of the remaining
four can be seated on the second once
the first chair is occupied the second
chair can be filled in four ways you
should be able to answer the next
question assuming one person is seated
on the first chair and another on the
second in how many ways can the third
chair be occupied
it's easy two out of the five are seated
on the first two chairs only three
remain if one person is seated on the
first chair and another on the second
then the third chair can be occupied by
any one of the remaining three people
three ways in our first session based on
permutations and combinations we
discussed the two important rules of
counting and is multiplication or is
addition so do we multiply these or add
them to know the answer just read out
what you have solved will it be filling
the first or the second or the third
chair or will it be filling the first
and the second and the third chair of
course it will be and we need to look at
the ways in which all three chairs are
occupied so we multiply these ways and
we get the answer as 60 ways if there
are five people then there are 60 ways
in which these three chairs can be
occupied let me modify the question a
bit this time we have five people and we
have been provided with five chairs
again the chairs are in a row in how
many ways can the chairs be occupied
what does this mean in simple words the
question is asking us for all possible
arrangements of five people on these
five chairs again let's take these five
chairs as five slots and using our usual
technique let's go slot by slot in how
many ways can the first chair be
occupied any one of the five people can
be seated on the first chair so there
are five different ways in which the
first chair can be occupied understand
the situation now one of these five is
seated on the first chair once this has
happened in how many ways can the second
chair be occupied as there are four
people remaining one of those four can
be seated on the second chair the second
chair can be occupied in four ways once
these two chairs are occupied the third
one can be occupied in three ways and
similarly two ways for the fourth chair
and just one person remains for the
fifth one one way in which the fifth
chair can be occupied if four people are
seated in the initial fall and to get
the answer we multiply these ways five
times four is 20 20 times 3 is 60 and 60
times 2 is 120 120 ways is the answer
120 ways in which five people can occupy
five chairs this is also equal to five
factorial
now books would ask you to memorize this
arranging five people on five chairs as
five factorial or n people on n chairs
as n factorial but don't memorize this
you have to understand how we arrived at
a 5 factorial after watching this video
I am sure you've understood why but if
this video was a little too fast for you
please go through it again as many
questions are built around this concept